check out this shot of Taylor Swift and  Tom Hiddleston holding hands during  their Wednesday date night out  twenty-six-year-old is looking stylish  and her black velvet dress and check out  the sexy cutout right in the middle  dressing like jailer isn't cheap for  strappy sandals by Nicholas Kirkwood  retail for about 695 bucks and her itro  crossbody bag goes for $2,000 the couple  that dresses together stays together  Tom's blue button-up is also by each row  very dapper the pair dined at Hill Stone  restaurant in Santa Monica and an eye  witness tells et they were laughing  touching and holding hands and get this  the onlooker even saw him kiss her at  the table but they weren't alone we're  told the couple had several security  guards standing by and of Taylor smile  is any indication it looks like she put  her drama with Kim Kardashian and Kanye  West behind her at least for the night